oh
[Musique]
dans nos archives pour célébrer les 40
ans de starmania
parce que la toute première
représentation de l'opéra rock de michel
berger et luc plamondon s'est déroulée à
paris presque exactement 40 ans le 10
avril 1979 au palais des congrès de
paris avec bon nombre d'interprètes
québécois on a reconnu fabienne
thibeault il y avait également nanette
workman y avait claude dubois il y avait
dit à mme dufresne
mais les premières critiques les
critiques parues dans les médias ont été
assez négative dont on a critiqué décors
costumes mais le public lui pas si
enthousiaste voici donc les commentaires
qu'on a recueilli après la première de
magna à paris les connecteurs n'ont pas
été impressionnés par des personnages
évoluent sur un plateau nu entouré d'une
centaine d'appareils aux particuliers
bien
en particulier nanette workman j'ai
beaucoup de mal à comprendre ce qu'elle
dit qu'est ce qui vous plaît plus
j'ai pas les mises en scène
surtout pas
je trouve
je compare un peu avec l'air fait qu'il
veuille trois fois
a paris une fois
en angleterre
ça me plaît
en dansant
dans ce métier là rien n'est jamais
accomplie ont toujours commencé alors
c'est pour moi c'est la condition d'un
travail de trois un bon c'est là je
croyais que caen
le spectacle existe rey s'est défini on
se tourne les pouces mais c'est pas du
tout comme cet aspect maintenant est-ce
que non tous les soirs le spectacle est
différent on essaie de changer des
choses d'améliorer très très très bien
fonctionné tant que ça fait 40 ans mais
le public connaissait déjà les chansons
oui parce que l'album de starmania lui
parut l'année d'avant à l'automne 1978
avec un titre beaucoup plus longs au
départ le titre complet c'était
starmania ou la passion de johnny
rockfort selon les évangiles télévisée
quel beau libé d'avoir gardé finalement
que starmania
donc c'est intéressant de retourner dans
nos archives en 1968 pour voir comment
le plamondon expliqué c'était quoi star
manière il nous présentait pour la
première fois ses personnages si marca
les personnages sont des personnages
d'aujourd'hui mais qui vivent dedans
dans un contexte de l'an 2000 des
joueurs et ja serveuse automate par
exemple qui a servi de loin de grandes
café qui ne voient jamais le soleil et
qui chante sa recherche du soleil via le
businessman qui vit en haut de son
gratte-ciel
et qui dominent le monde enfin qui
contrôle son univers des autres sans
gratte ciel j'aurais voulu autrement
[Musique]
quoi faire au numéro
dans l'avion
sur la vie
[Musique]
ce
alors la première au québec s'est
déroulée l'année suivante manque en 1986
des critiques est assez négative pour la
première parisienne les critiques
étaient très positives au québec
voici donc les commentaires des premiers
spectateurs québécois de starmania les
mondiaux était merveilleux le meilleur
j'ai vu jusqu'à date butoir malien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
excellent fantastique très beau fameux
tellement donné mais c'est excellent
franchement merveilleuse super c'est le
chant des steppes france castrés de
partir de la première troupe québécoise
a chanté ego trip et donc lui clairement
très heureux de la réaction du public
mais aussi jamais comment ça va vraiment
se dérouler on espère qu'il ya pas de
pépins que tout se déroule
merveilleusement bien
il avait cette anecdote savoureuse pour
l'animatrice suzanne lévesque
pour ce qui est des premières
représentations de starmania au québec
il ya de la fumée d'un show à un moment
donné dans la mise en scène est la
première fois qu on a fait chaud dans la
salle tant la subite arriver le
détecteur de fumée partie la sonnette
d'alarmé s'est mise à sonner
les pompiers sont arrivés on va te
premier public est un public de pompiers
[Rires]
vodkaster spectacle visionnaire sans
prise est absolument et plus le temps
passe et plus on le découvre cet homme
d'affaires qui veut ré tout puissant qui
veut gérer le monde on pense à dans
notre homme cette animatrice de télé qui
se montre 24 heures sur 24 c'est la télé
réalité la solitude la peur de vieillir
le terrorisme les gangs de rue la
violence dans les pas du tout ça se
retrouve dans starmania et fabien petits
bouts qui était la première la première
serveuse automate lance cette semaine un
livre et raconte son starmania c'est le
titre de ce livre aux éditions
flammarion québec
comment une jeune chanteuse 26 ans a
vécu cette aventure de starmania si son
récit qu'il va rester très spécial comme
expérience dans ton livre et qui semble
directement
merci stéphane